hey Terrell advice from the fighter and
make sure you listen to that one well
who give you advice of a mass shooter
well you have nowhere to go this is run
Adam according to broadcast of this
everyone's going what the fight talking
i have been in her who check this out a
couple proposed so he hit me up by four
or five weeks before i was came in my
girl and I huge fans were coming to the
show he was it would I would love it if
you could help me propose to her I don't
know what we could do I went I know
exactly what we can do how about turn
fan questions we pretend that we need
volunteers i'll pick you you guys come
up here then i give you the Mike she was
like hell yeah its own now for all you
listeners out there that doesn't mean
we're gonna do that show no so please
don't email and say I want to propose my
girl it's it's gonna be a very very rare
yeah thing may be the only time but yeah
it's very it was very very nice fun
imagine she said no I would you know
that's all I was worried about I was
like cuz she looked like you know yeah
right a man sometimes god damn do you
imagine people say no you know I feel
like it's rare I feel like it but if you
do it in front of a crowd you put more
pressure on her to say yes cuz she's
like I don't embarrass him so I'm say
yes right now later on you go hey listen
hey listen I don't know all that stuff
back there give me a proposal yeah man I
think what they're doing with cris
cyborg 140 if you watch the documentary
she release it's just she's literally
taking years off her life making this
wait really she's crying she's literally
killing herself to make 140 it's such a
struggle for and she's doing it to face
who you know I'm saying like she's
literally doing it to face these girls
who don't land a punch on her like that
girl came up to 40 inch that she's
really not that that's not a natural
weight yeah she's a great muy Thai
striker okay it doesn't matter man they
can't compete physically with cyborg
they don't land punches really she beats
the [ __ ] out of these girls man it's
like assignment competition I think she
she I think she's by far the number one
female fighter on the planet but you you
have to do something with her so this is
why I think they're doing 40s she's
killing it [ __ ]
yourself to make man they're building up
fight so the public gets familiar with
her and then they're gonna start
throwing the stars Misha Holly maybe
Rhonda because if they just stole right
away it did no way yeah 45 her it'd have
to be 40 she's they're gonna have to
catch weight at 40 or because if you saw
it but this how much sense so Dana does
the the YouTube show I've never seen it
so don't it don't if I get misquote on
this [ __ ] whatever I've never seen it
looking for a fight or whatever youtube
show which I have my thoughts on him
didn't you to show anyways so he has a
YouTube show why not looking for a fight
at 145 females all he does is go around
looking for 145 females yeah because
your cyber what's killing herself so
have a 145 division but have a show
dedicated just 145 pound women yes to
build this division round side work
she's so good you can do that let's get
into some five talk yeah I suppose it
would look at oh how tall is linux X own
eight more carts fighting boy Nate's
fighting a cold tamdan mccrory remember
that guy I guess he's back in all the
jutsu guy yeah the barn cat what
happened to the barn cat he took like
four years yeah he see his dipped out
for a couple years that's an intriguing
fight tamdan mccrory tough dude barn cat
he's a tough customer he's been around
the block he's you know I had tough
customers some simple been a great
[ __ ] description tough customer is
exactly what you call it oh yeah that's
an intriguing fight he's a jiu-jitsu
player like amazing late mark Nate Nate
Dogg stuff to submit ah let's see the
main card we have the main card holders
name on pre lengthy we are Andre feely
fighting Hawker dias anything on that I
love watching feel if I i think is that
actually feely what else you got Oh
first member to her happy birthday Bobby
great fun it's like a fun fight this is
for sure Bobby green cracks me a rabbit
be no just like you yo you'll hit him
you'll you'll hit him just miss him
he'll get hill looking up now he's gonna
get I sorry he just talked to you
nah nah sorry he wags his finger I what
else she got it was matumbo is it co man
we got will Brooks and a cowboy Oliveira
I'm a will brook fan will Brooks as a
means built like a goddamn running back
and cowboy kid was his last loss to
cowboy the real cowboy thanks al uh I
think he's picked up a win since then
let's see it's take a look at his record
yeah he beat Jimmy yeah he beat James
moon tosser a nice I'll take will Brooks
in that fight though and I think mrs.
wills next fight a host to Ross Pearson
right what is him yeah let's see that
main event main event five rounder
Lineker Dobson that's a fun fun fun card
yeah maybe not like a ton of stars or
big name value or anything like as far
as the actual matchups yeah I'm not mad
at it but the the big the big moment of
the whole thing of the whole event has
to be crazy horse do you know so you
know do you know the the background of
Crazy Horse and wanderlei and turnin box
thing so back in he's phyllis NM i'll
fill it in in 2006 croak crazy horse
gets into a fight backstage in the
locker rooms with Cristiano Marcello
who's on Xander later chute boxe team
Marcello triangles him puts him out cold
he wakes up and according to crazy horse
crazy was the only person that's ever
backed this story up he gets up first
person he sees is a 205 pounds Jack to
this [ __ ] Wanderlei Silva and knocks him
out cold not that's what crazy or said
happened wanted laid eggs different why
do i begs to differ that's so openly
that's that's what it basically
Wanderlei is cornering this kid solely
because him and crazy works have so much
beef through the years and like crazy
was always talking [ __ ] to him so if
android corners this kid I think he's
the number one ranked featherweight kick
boxer in the world he's fighting and
he's fights crazy horse van der lies
just giving him the throat slash in the
corner whole deal examples got into a
fight again in the
background crazy horse crazy horse was
trained at Jackson someone's getting the
better of him in sparring he went to his
car got a baseball bat and went back
into the ring he's crazy okay she is
crazy horse [ __ ] Maria in crazy horse
crazy horses aren't that crazy so make
sure you re making me crazy crazy horse
was the fame ya never gives so see that
crazy so hot not this crazy crazy horse
so so crazy horse flights and I don't
know you might be able to make it out a
little bit in the video here I'm gonna
play but he's looking straight to the
camera saying vandala you know I knocked
you a shout the whole time and this is
how the fight goes down
I was the [ __ ] [ __ ] the fights quick oh
it's real quick what it's real quite
explosive as a [ __ ] first team
all crazy well let's not do it jumping
and look at this he runs over to wanda
lee god damn yeah is that like as [ __ ]
he's crunk well so he's about to lay on
someone does this you can see the sukkot
that he did right before he does the
crotch chop backflip to Wanderlei oh
damn and then he and then he sat down
down baby behind or no now will you
hesitant to do fuller house like it is
there a party that goes I'm over there
that day no no no it's just the opposite
in fact is a bit I actually well no it's
not it at all I am I've stayed close
with everybody I don't I'll do a show
that'll last one year like I did a show
surviving suburbia I did a show called
racing dad they only had one year runs
and I stayed close with all the people
on it and if you do eight years of
people like we did I just don't believe
in dissing genuine relationships if you
like the people yeah the fan I and these
were kids and they all grew up and I've
stayed close with everybody in the damn
thing and so we we it was not even a
thought and stainless made it happen in
Jeff Franklin and Bob Boyett same guys
and Tom Miller the same people that made
the original series and they stayed true
to it so it was it was a hoot it wasn't
like I'm not Spock you know it was like
denying that I'm going back to the
bridge of the interprets where we do
nothing but like like Brian said a lot
of people i think i know i was cuz you
see Danny tanner you know Bob's how you
playing this wholesome dad like your
kind of everyone's dad he said for our
generation use our bill cosby you don't
say like five Maggie could trust me yeah
like you could literally [ __ ] I mean I I
get in but I get all my felf done in my
standup exactly i don't have to i don't
have take your home and roofie you there
yeah yeah he stood there Bobby a
briefcase to my gigs though just in case
today but it's all his boys in it
nothing but not but then when you see
him do stand-up it's like I I didn't
know he was that sort of comic and I
like oh shoot that gun I'm not that blue
now
I think it's because I got older
everything else just gotten bluer and a
lot of people just if you look at a lot
of comics everybody's favorite comics
the language the content is mine's
really nine-year-old filth I mean it's
yeah it's a lot but but I'm evolving to
like I'm as my stand-up is growing and I
want to do a new special soon but i'm
waiting till the selections over because
it's too painful to do something well
good this is on talk to me talk to me
about your just talk to me by your
thoughts on this well it's painful is
painful to see all the bullying and the
name calling and how celebrity has risen
all anybody cares about is celebrity and
fame yeah nothing to do with moving the
earth forward and and that's what it's a
question of each country is supposed to
try to do rather than and then we of
course we've got you know terror people
i'd like to give them plug because that
way they'll come after me you know it's
always good to mention them my god i
would do a 40 minute set to do a scene
with her not do it Kevin Hart's amazing
but batty they did the URI but let's go
buddy i'll talk about what we would do
to Halle Berry that'll mean ass but the
listeners I love that you're saying that
Brian goes like I wonder for husbands
good all day baby all day with you all
day that's what I say how I Barry that's
how I cat called chicks with the and it
sounds like a good thing you guys say
often and obviously it doesn't put women
off at all wait I want you stick your
head out the window and go all day with
you it's all day with that let's you
know Prius I'm here Brian all day uh-huh
yeah all week and a hell up okay getting
my [ __ ] I bread anytime you want baby
my back seats yours oh [ __ ] day I'm
friends with Bob Saget that's what I do
please don't drop my name drunk yeah
okay but but in the 40s it was just wolf
calls you know his construction workers
regnum how good is lying you know how
weird is it doesn't it what I want to
know who decide to I've never done in my
life I want to know the first guy to do
that and actually think it's gonna it's
never worked I'm not excited for UFC to
apply man amazing card oh is it okay
Jose my card it makes it could be by
Michael Johnson got added to that talk
to you did it really yeah yeah what yeah
that got officially announced yesterday
could be Michael Johnson selling our
card I've no idea Fitz will be on the
main card
on yes yes the best UFC car of all time
[ __ ] paper hands down [ __ ] on 200 we
just gotta make sure no injuries happen
Bob we'll watch it together we'll get
some popcorn we got what a month and 14
days or so month in two weeks well that
very excited Conrad's about 10 years ago
UFC was not nothing nothing nope now
it's that's pretty sort of four billion
dollars uh-huh very interesting when you
see rich white people you're putting a
fence around that and you're excluding
them from the problem you're there are
gluten what what I'm saying there i
don't know i don't want to hear a white
successful person tell me what the
solution is nobody is yeah i know so
it's very hard to watch the news BK eyes
at who's reporting it all white people
are says they're giving you their
perspective on it and yes it's obviously
not working you don't say so the more
african-americans who have a voice we're
actually in an average it come out care
that's what we need and in a premier
african-american newscaster on CNN isn't
given the latitude now to represent
their heritage and that is your you're
basically still coming through the voice
of white America so I think the solution
is we start painting people everybody
blue okay so we did every all colors
everybody other news should be burning
blue [ __ ] Smurfs and we chromakey
just beautiful Mickey Bob Saget the
answers Bob Saget with the answers
everybody should be the same color I
agree how would help and then they'll
just hate religion but they'll still
hate all shame really all same real
awesome hahaha they asked me to do a
part in a half-baked they gave me the
script and the line was a sec dick for
Coke ya know because it was a drug rehab
scene and I said the line with pride and
the best part was a guy named David
Edwards Edwards or Edmonds damn and I'm
sorry Dave and and I said I used to suck
dick for Coke and he yells out I seen
him and that's the best that's the best
line of duty I seen I seen him is better
than I see no but it was it was funny
because that at the time was right
before I did the aristocrats right
before a bunch of appearances on
Entourage you Kratos a lot of people
like
flip the zeitgeist and then I was I knew
my life had arrived when I was on the
Rolling Stone as a maverick full-page
picture of me right after I before
Billie Joe Armstrong as a maverick
simply because I said I suck dick for
Coke that's cool right so that's it but
you don't want to say it in your normal
life but it can change in the risk last
thing you were laughing so hard you
couldn't get the joke out was that was
that you in the aristocrats yes I
couldn't do it because I was so shamed
that I was doing it I don't know I was
on stage and a stripper was on right
before me and this is celosa career-low
and she had pie pans with matches taped
to the pie pans over over her breasts
and her nether regions and and which
isn't in the netherlands his hand and
she set it all on fire just two matches
on each pie pan and blew herself out and
then went and now the comedy of bob
saget so I followed that and it was like
so far so depressing all four it's wet
Joey [ __ ] depressing and she wasn't
attractive it was pretty sad I was she's
not listening yeah whatever i changed it
out uh but her eyes just popped out
chill Alaska Alaska stuff dude you would
not get me doing standard I bet now it's
good i mean their Studios there I know
people that go there and yeah I'm there
but I'm gonna ask them what strip club
from a second no in fact there was one
time I know you want me to talk more I
know you can't get enough a long time
Stamos and cool yay said let's go to a
strip club just the three of us I'm like
guys he crazy and what full house in a
strip club is this and it showed been
off for ten years we didn't care so he
went to this club I don't want to say
which one it was but it was off the
freeway and it's all nude but no no
booze yeah and so we go inside and and
John's ago where I got us all hooked up
everything's taken care of we're in the
front row then the guy comes up with a
microphone ladies and gentlemen we have
special guests here tonight Oh couple of
crisis can you tanner
jammu day let me dust your tits it was
just horrific terrace poor idea Stan I
was my idea but